you hate to hear about this kind of
thing but Channing Tatum and Jenna Dewan
Tatum filed for divorce it's so sad it's
too bad yeah it is too bad and sources
close to the couple say that the split
was was amicable and it comes at a time
when I'm sorry that's I'm sorry that is
one of our cue card people and they're
distracting me what is it what is it
Dana I'm sorry it's just
Channing Tatum is my celebrity free pass
celebrity free pass that's that's for
you and your spouse pick a celebrity
that you'd eat just let the other ones
sleep with huh exactly my husband picked
Chrissy Teigen and I picked Channing
Tatum and he's going to be single so
yeah but you don't think that Channing
Tatum is is gonna really reach out to
you after watching this show and you
think he's gonna see this and reach out
no of course not why would he even go
out with me I mean he's an a-list movie
star and Who am I I mean I don't think
Channing Tatum even knows I'm alive okay
Tina do me a favor and just and stop
flipping cards okay now look they just
they just announced the divorce it's not
like he's gonna go back into the dating
world you know right away yeah I get
that all I said was that I had a crush
on him it's not like I'm expecting him
to call me okay Dana Dana it's really
unprofessional did you just put that
card away please yeah I mean just do me
a favor Dana
thing that now won't encourage her
Dana put all the cards away yeah just
get a hold of yourself Dana what
chanting really needs now is time with
this buddy upside down
as I was saying what Channing really
needs now is time with his buddies time
with guys to gain some respect of
perspective to get his mind off his pain
it's time to heal from what must be a
very difficult situation
[Applause]
you